The Joe Rogan Experience a lot of people
that live in the city eventually wind up
going the opposite they wind up going to
like a [ __ ] house in the country I'm
dying to get it I have yeah it's funny I
feel like when I was I grew up in in
Whitman's small town and I was obsessed
with Springsteen like get out of this
town Born to Run and I I did it and now
I still listen to Springsteen and still
get moved but now it's like I gotta get
a home and with a with grass and you see
the star it's like the same motivation
but before it was to go to the city but
now I want to be
in the country yeah my friend Jeff has
always been like this die-hard New York
City guy I love the energy of the city
he's lived there his whole life and then
he got a place on Fire Island and he's
like I couldn't live in the city if I
didn't have this place now because I
know it keeps you able I can stay in the
city because I have my place yeah you
get that decompression yeah that's what
I found well I I moved to Colorado for a
brief amount of time in like 2009 I
lived in uh Gold Hill which is like 3
000 feet above Boulder like I went full
out 148 Acres like wow log house the
whole deal but my wife got pregnant and
you can't like if you are a person who
lives at sea level and you go to 8 000
feet and you're pregnant it's like you
have the flu every day it was horrible
yeah like she was wrecked and then we
went back to LA for a few days and she
was normal and then I realized ah [ __ ]
so we had a bail can't do it yeah it was
rough that was good man living up there
was [ __ ] magical it was like
everything just went
well Human animals are were part of the
earth yeah it's our home and cities are
not natural right you don't see you're
you're it's man-made lighting as soon as
it gets dark it's man-made lighting
everywhere and you have to turn off the
lights to find Darkness you don't have
this natural this thing of like you know
uh the there's certain parts of the day
where the breeze comes like if you live
anywhere on a coast there's a sea breeze
and then there's the hot part of the day
and there's you know and it's it's and
you're watching the grass go green and
then gray you're watching the trees die
it's part of it tells your brain how
life works I think it makes you less
afraid of dying that you watch
everything die and renew every year and
you touch you get a sense of what speed
you're actually supposed to be running
at because the the city life and also
the online life and the and the phone
life
is overworking everybody's brains and
their systems people are texting right
before bedtime and it's just but being
out there in nature where it's like no
it's getting dark cool off it's getting
dark there's no sense of getting dark in
the city it's you know yeah um you watch
in the world go to sleep and then the
different sounds you're hearing the
birds go to bed and then insects come
out all those things are like are
reminding you how your system actually
what's going on in your chemistry is
connected to all that yeah there's also
a thing about going into the woods and
being around nature where it's like it's
like a nourishment that your body is not
normally getting it's like you feel like
you're getting like a little something
like oh yeah I need this like there's
something in this that like your body is
supposed to interface with yeah it's
good for your physical health there's
all these studies yeah not just your
mental health well if people don't see
the Sun for a certain amount of time
they go insane
so if you think about the original
people they saw that six guys starts
like that really full Sky Stars was
normal for every human being to see that
every night yeah and a lot of people
never see it never see one star if you
live in a city you don't see this the
night sky unless it's Los Angeles you
see stars everywhere there
killing their wives and the guy I went
to
um Hawaii once went to the Keck
Observatory it's on the big island and
it's way up there you have to drive
literally through the clouds as we were
driving I was like [ __ ] it's cloudy this
is gonna suck We're not gonna see
anything and then you literally drive
through the clouds and the image that
you get because the Big Island uses all
diffused lighting because of the the
Keck Observatory so when you get up
there the view where you're at you know
like 13 000 feet or something like that
the view of space is insane it you
really feel like you're in a spaceship
you don't feel like you're on Earth
anymore you feel like you're in a ship
with a glass seal and you're just
passing through the Milky Way I mean
it's [ __ ] wonderful yeah because
we're used to this perspective that
you're standing on Earth and that's up
but we're really looking across at other
people and you're looking down at the
Earth that like you're that you're
tacked down to but in reality you're
hanging upside down yeah and you're
really hanging out into everything
everything in the whole universe is it's
not above your head you're look if you
look like this it's really that's the
really correct perspective yeah you know
well that's why all these ancient
cultures were obsessed with
constellations and we don't give a [ __ ]
about them first that's why they built
[ __ ] like that to get up yes yeah and
also built things that mimicked the
constellations like the Mayans and the
Egyptians this the way they've
formulated their structures it all like
aligned with certain constellations and
it was very important to them well think
about back when people were before there
was like skyscrapers airplanes that you
couldn't go up you could only go like
six feet high right right and you could
maybe build something that was like I
don't know three like a a castle yeah
that's kind of high but those pyramids
and
I know I sound like an idiot it's
something you guys [ __ ] dropped acid
while I was watching OJ but she's got
wacky in here that was Hills there's
mountains right yes mountains are high
yeah but they're but they're high in you
don't you're not you don't have like a
drop but you're not really seeing right
and also I I you know unless you lived
in the mountains and that became normal
right but the ability to go let's go the
way the [ __ ] up there and see from up
there and feel like where how where is
the sky yeah it's also very humbling to
people to be encountered to encounter
like like uh undeniable Majesty like the
insane Majesty of the universe like
that's how people are like around
mountains around the ocean things that
are so epic that it's like it calms
people down yeah in a way that's why
people are so chill around beaches yeah
like beach communities they're always
like kind of relaxed yeah this thing is
telling you over and over again
it doesn't give a [ __ ] it doesn't give a
[ __ ] you're a speck and there's this
Force this incredible Force when waves
get high yeah you're just watching them
crash and it's just telling you without
you're even thinking about it
intellectually [ __ ] okay I get it put it
in perspective if you think you are very
very important and then you're on a
mountain you're like oh I'm not
important at all no this means nothing
and Nature's brutal yeah Nature's brutal